[Federer] Open science is really an umbrella term thatincludes a lot of different practices that enablepeople to access the results of science.
[Zaringhalam] When I
first learned about open science I think it was
best described to me as really resting on three
pillars: you have open data, meaning that the data
are made openly available, that they're shared. You
have open source, which means that the underlying
analytical tools and software and code are made
openly available, and then you have open access,
which is that publications, that are sort of thesynthesis of the data and the results that came
after the analysis, are also made openly availablefor folks to read. [Instructor] 100% accuracy on...
[Federer] NLM is reallyinterested in creating expertise andknowledge about data, not just in, you
know, the research institution or in libraries, butalso preparing the public to be more data savvy.
[Zaringhalam] Having as many people as possible who are
able to access the data, who are able to look
under the hood, make science more rigorous
because you have more folks who are able to
sort of tap into this data, tap into your code, have
access to the publications that result from it
and engage in this consensus building that is so
incredibly important and foundational for scienceto move forward.
[Federer] We're in a position that we can
talk with publishers about why open access is
important or talk with them about why they should
be instituting data citation, which would make
it easier for us to track data. We have a really
unique position as a medical library, of our sort
of standing, to really help push forward some of
the practices that will lead to more open science.
[Upbeat music]